I want you guys to do right now is be a
little bit more involved as I okay good
firstly why want to do is turn to your
neighbor I said one lucky your neighbor
look at them deeply in their eyes that's
it and then give them a nice warm
handshake
that's perfect all right now when you
look at your other neighbor on the other
side of you okay and tell them that you
excited to be here today
okay thanks for that what when you got
to do now is give each other a nice
wonderful fluids personally I want to
thank you for doing that because before
I got on stage today I made a bet of one
of my friends that I'd be able to get
everyone in this room to smile so you
guys have one leaf extra fifty pounds so
thanks for that okay so now that I'm now
that we've got wood out of the way what
I want to do is tell you about my
inspiration for my talk today I have
this habit of when I am meet new people
I would talk to you as if you've been
one of my best friends for years and at
the start of this year so in generally I
was doing that with a first-year student
and I was asking about how her time at
university was how it was and how house
was finding it and at first I was saying
it was okay so on and so forth but then
while still speaking what actually
happens I noticed a single tear vote on
her cheek and then she went on to say
she was actually really struggling here
at University the reasons were
struggling it had nothing to do for
course it was simply because she was
struggling to make friends and for me I
have to say that actually broke my heart
um it was so bad that in fact I had to
even pretend like I had something in my
eye at the time so that I could work
away a few tears that laughs kinda so if
you had done that as well
and yeah for me that was so shocking to
hear because I know in my time here at
university on campus everybody was
always so friendly and it was something
that I really wasn't used to because I'm
from London right so if anybody if a
stranger started smiling at you or
started to be friendly that's normally a
very good sign that something bad is
about to happen
so it's normally a good sign that you
should start running but it turns out
that when you're in an environment like
this when if I'm aware everybody is
friendly to each other
it's actually really contagious so I
found myself that after being here for
about a week I was actually the person
starting conversations with people I was
the person smile at strangers I was
supposed to making new connections and
since that's happened it's been
something that I said I'm going to
continue for the whole of my life and
since doing that has made a massive
impact on both my personal and
professional life but since this is
Ted's I don't want his comment stage and
tell you about our personal experiences
just because you think I might be making
things up so I did a little bit of
research and I've got some scientists
actually backed me up but before I get
into this please forgive me if I say any
of the researchers names incorrectly it
turns out that the more successful you
are the more difficult you have
certainly miss to say for some reason so
yeah if I dismantle anyone's name like
now please forgive me for that okay so
to begin with professor Robert safe off
um did experiment and found that the
most accurate predictor of the length of
your life is the number of social
connections you actually make that
research was backed up by Berkman and
Siam in 1978 where they studied 7,000
Californian adults and during that time
they found that your average the average
number of social ties he had the higher
that number was was the higher you the
more likely was to live a longer life
and that's even after you control for
factors such as socioeconomic status
your lifestyle your diet or even your
DNA study by gen ka and San P in 1997
actually found that if you compare the
performance of a group of friends
compared to people of associates or
strangers that they will always
outperform those given people when you
give them a cognitive or a motor task so
why are we better with friends
it's actually quite simple it's probably
something we all know ourselves to be
honest when you have a group of friends
you will always communicate better on
top of that when you have your friends
you're going to be way more supportive
feature of each other so you're going to
be way more encouraging and you're going
to help each other reach your goals and
the other thing when you have when you
as we all know you're going to be a lot
more committed to each other do you get
hard when when stress starts to mount
and so on and so forth you're still
going to be there because you know at
end of day your friendship is deeper
than whatever task it is that you're
facing and when you combine all these
factors together it actually helps to
reduce your stress levels and as we all
know the has we all know sorry though
your stress level is the better you are
because yeah it has made you a better
version of yourself so me personally I'm
an entrepreneur by profession that's why
I do and in the business world we've
actually known about the whole secret of
making friends or strangers for a very
long time in fact is something so
important that we gave it its own name
and it's called networking the thing
about networking is that a lot of people
do it with the completely the wrong way
around what they will do is find
somebody that they feel they can get
something from and simply pursue that
friendship or network or connection just
so they can get everything they can from
that person what I can personally say is
that behind every success have ever had
every major success that is when I look
back at it it's always its foundation
has always been in a strong friendship
when I started my first business when I
was 17 I actually found my business
partner in my best friend and even
though that business no longer is this
we've gone on to start new businesses
and I can tell you without a shadow of a
doubt if if he wasn't my best friend at
the time or even now then these
businesses that we started would not
exist at all because you go through so
many stresses you gave you so many hard
times is only your friendships that will
help you to keep on pursuing and keep on
going for
in fact I'd go out even goes far the
same that nobody no matter what your job
is your profession or your dreams can be
successful without other people I like
to base my life on something covered in
a book and it simply says we cannot be
poor to success rather we need to be
lifted and I don't know about any of you
guys but I would never lift up somebody
I don't like
it's that simple but as we all know
because we all have friends our friends
our three friends at least will lift us
at every opportunity possible and that
will make it a lot easier for us to
achieve our dreams or goals on top of
that no matter what you want to do for
life you're always going to need other
people we need people to work with us we
need people to work for us sometimes
need to work for other people and
whatever it is that you go in to sell
because ultimately we all the
salespeople these days you need other
people to buy from you so people are
always going to be the key to your
success in fact the higher you go up in
the corporate world on the ladder of
success what you'll begin to find is all
the technical skills you've been
developing over all these years will
mean less and less and the only things
that will begin to matter are your
social skills okay now let me actually
answer the question so why do I make
friends or strangers the first reason is
because personally I believe every
single human has an infinite amount of
potential so for me when I see anybody
in this room here today I have no idea
who you are right now I've no idea what
you've done and I've no idea what you're
going to do but I believe that if when
you put your when you put hard work
behind yourself you dedicate your life
to something and you and destroy your
complete focus you can go and do
anything you dream of and to me that's
an extremely exciting prospect
so right now in this room I could be
looking at next prime minister of the UK
or I could be looking that beautiful of
billionaires I don't know what if I
never get to know you if I never take
the time to talk to you
and
we're going to find that out double
reason why I take time to make friends
of strangers is because you never know
where you can learn from somebody we've
all gone through unique experiences in
life we've all been raised differently
we're all from different cultures we
will have something different about us
so for me I always see every individual
person there's a unique opportunity to
learn something new learn something new
about that person learn something about
their culture but what that ultimately
does is teaches me something new about
myself and makes me a better person and
my third and final reason as to why I
believe in making stranger friends with
strangers Valvo is because you actually
never know what that person is going
through sometimes it's not about me it's
not about you it's not always about us
it's sometimes just like the first-year
student I mentioned the start of this
talk you never know what they're going
through at that moment in time and by
you taking the time out to speak to
somebody you never know what sort of
encouragement you could be giving them
or what difference you could be making
to their day so their week their month
or even a year even if you look into
loads of studies into depression and
problems lots of suicide yes you find
that if the right person intervened at
the right time you could have actually
saved somebody's life so that's an
important friendship actually is okay my
challenge for all of you guys here today
and anybody watching this at a later
date is over the next seven days I want
you to just try this one thing just
literally find one stranger or somebody
don't know very well and make the time
to actually make a genuine friendship
with them find out something new about
them asking a few questions and I
guarantee if you do that once a day for
the next seven days you're going to find
out something amazing probably most of
those conversations my end of this
simply just making someone's day leaving
the other person with a smile on their
face but one out of the seven people
will be something that will change your
life so that's my challenge to you okay
to end I was going to come and give you
a very inspirational story of some sort
but in all honesty I couldn't find
anything good enough
so what I'm going to do instead is I'm
going to give you a quote that I've read
an internet last night and it goes like
this friendship is like wetting yourself
the reason is because everybody can see
it but only you can feel the warm
feeling thank you very much
you